all right people of the internet good
news and bad news here when it comes to
quidditch Champions it's only been a day
but we do have some additional news now
specifically regarding the play test now
I know everybody usually wants the bad
news first so let's get the bad news out
of the way first of all I do not have a
code I have not gotten anything yet and
even if I did which I don't but even if
I did I would not be able to discuss
anything that I played because it seems
that everyone who is getting into this
play test will be under a strict NDA not
to talk about anything at all that they
see so here's the exact wording that was
posted on the Discord you can see that
it says anyone involved in the play test
should not speak about it here in this
server or elsewhere online because the
play tests are under NDA we will not be
providing any public additional info
about them at this time you only need to
sign up for play tests once so if you
signed up already you're all set stay
tuned for future play test opportunities
so yeah that's the bad news there some
of you out there watching this right now
may be actually playing the game as soon
as this weekend that is according to IGN
they said that the play tests are going
to start on the 21st this was also
retweeted by the official developer so I
haven't seen anyone official say that's
when it begins but the fact that they
retweeted this it would seem that they
have given IGN this information and so I
mentioned there was good news too the
good news is that emails are apparently
already going out the first Discord
message here says congrats to the
Champions who will be participating in
our first limited play test for those of
you who did not receive an owl stay
tuned for more play test opportunities
in the future now at the time of me
recording this video I have not received
anything you out there watching you may
have received something so make sure you
check your email see if you guys have
anything but then also read very
carefully what it says about the NDA you
guys are not going to be allowed to
discuss it if in fact you can play now
ndas certainly aren't anything new but
the circumstances around this one the
way that this game was just announced
out of nowhere and some people are going
to be playing it apparently as soon as
this weekend makes it a little bit
strange so for those of you who are out
there wanting more news right away it
seems like you're going to have to wait
at least a little bit because there's
nothing about a date on this we don't
know how long the NDA asked we don't
know when the next wave of emails are
going out there's still a lot we don't
know at this point but the main message
of this very brief video update is first
of all check your email and then also
anyone who is playing the game won't be
able to talk about it until that NDA
lifts which apparently right now it does
not have a date on it in fact they may
never be able to talk about what they
experience in that limited play test
because the fact that you know it's not
representative of the final game things
could change all those kinds of things
so as soon as we do know more and we can
actually post and talk about here on the
channel you guys already know we'll be
covering the game here if you have any
questions leave them in the comments
below of course there's still a lot we
don't know about this game but I'll try
and do my best to answer them as always
guys thank you all so much for watching
I'll talk to you again soon